the 11 hours that Haley had with her son
Jack will stay with her forever when he
was born four years ago in Telford the
delivery was traumatic mistakes were
made that cost her son his life when I
heard what happened with Jack and what
it was and someone told me those another
lady the same day and their little lad
got his shoulder stock the same as what
my boy did and they took too long
getting him out and he died the day
before my Jack died and I didn't know
Hayley has long known that there were
many more cases like hers maternity
failings in Telford and Shrewsbury that
have devastated families now a leaked
report has revealed that the inquiry is
dealing with the biggest maternity
scandal the NHS has ever seen in total
270 cases that date back to 1979 it
includes 22 stillbirths 17 deaths of
babies after birth and 51 cases of
cerebral palsy or brain damage medical
failures and failures of human
compassion that created a culture that
was described as toxic that culture goes
back 40 years here in Shropshire the NHS
trust say that they apologise
unreservedly to the families involved
and that big improvements have been made
but even now they have to concede that
their maternity services still have
further to go but nobody can undo the
pain that the families have been through
Richton Rhiannon lost their daughter
Kate shortly after her birth I still
feel angry and I think I didn't have
such a brilliant wife beside me
supporting me it would be a lot
different losing your child losing your
baby watching her die in your arms is a
moment that changes your life forever
I feel bitter hatred quite frankly
towards certain indie
about trust who are enabling overseeing
not caring about baby death maternal
deaths now they know the scale of this
scandal they want corporate manslaughter
charges to follow for now
the inquiry is still working to
establish everything that went so badly
wrong Tom Parmenter Sky News Shropshire